bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur rt
français ce que vous diriez qu'il ya en
déficit de pédagogie la part de
l'exécutif
je ne sais pas s'il est difficile de
pédagogie un déficit de communication un
déficit d'explication la réalité c'est
que si partie aujourd'hui de la
population et l'opinion publique
n'adhère pas à cette mesure c'est
d'abord parce que c'est une mesure qui
est considéré comme excessivement
coercitives pour un certain nombre de
nos compatriotes que c'est une mesure
qui apparaît parfois contradictoires
avec eux des dispositions qui sont un
bien complice parce que tout simplement
on ne comprend pas pourquoi il faut les
excités impasse sanitaires pour aller
dans une terrasse de café que finalement
on peut circuler librement tu me manques
en portant un masque dans un rer ou dans
un mettront et puis ça apparaît aussi
parfois inefficaces c'est à dire que
finalement nota sanitaire est plutôt un
instrument dont l'objectif l'attend est
de pousser les gens à la vaccination
plutôt que de véritablement ralentir la
propagation du virus donc l'ensemble de
ces paramètres font que de toute façon
toute tentative d'explication aussi
volontairement rationnelle de l'exécutif
aura du mal vrai savon à convaincre les
plus récalcitrants à cet outil qui est
quand même l outil d'exception qui pose
de vrais problèmes en matière de
libertés publiques en matière de
principes d'égalité aussi comment est ce
que vous expliquez que ça mouvement de
contestation perdure et durer tout au
long de cet été
vous savez de toute façon la société
française est une société ça a été dit
par de nombreux observateurs ex-société
très fracturé une sas une société qui
n'a plus confiance pour une grande
partie d'entre elles dans l'exercice du
pouvoir politique
les réseaux ou les raisins de la colère
d'une certaine manière préexisté à cette
crise sanitaire préexisté à
l'instauration de ce dispositif
sanitaire d'eau que toute mesure
aujourd'hui l'exécutif a fortiori quand
ces mesures apparaissent pour un certain
nombre de personnes comme les mesures
liberticides attentatoire à leur vie
personnelle et ben sont des facteurs
avait des airs de
d'expression de cette colère est ce que
vous vous direz que l'exécutif a sa part
de responsabilité aussi dans cette
fracture de la société pour reprendre
vos termes est-ce que emmanuel macron
est dans une logique de confrontation
notamment entre les vacciner les non
vaccinés
alors il y là il a d'une part on essaie
par sa communication parfois par le
comportement aussi parfois aussi du
président de la république
ou de certains de ses lieutenants une
part de responsabilité dans cette
fracture mais cette facture elle est
lointaine ne date pas du mandat d'
emmanuel macron ce la réalité c'est que
l'on vit en france maintenant depuis
plusieurs décennies une lente mais
j'allais presque incommensurable crise
de la représentation politique ensuite
en effet le dispositif est un dispositif
le dispositif du pass sanitaire qui
fracturent d'une certaine manière des
principes avec lesquelles nous avons été
élevés avec lesquelles nous avons été
éduqués celui de la liberté notamment de
la liberté de circulation la liberté
d'accéder à un certain nombre de lieux
fracturé le principe d'égalité alors
d'aller vidame ans l'exécutif a raison
d'exciper que c'est une mesure qui est
une mesure transitoire mais la réalité
car même de toutes les lois d'exception
c'est que malheureusement très souvent
elles s'inscrivent dans la durée dans
les législations et la crainte aussi qui
est émise par un certain nombre de
manifestants c'est que ces mesures ne
soient pas que seulement que des mesures
transitoires avec les s'inscrivent plus
longuement dans notre vie quotidienne on
a beaucoup évoqué a le profil très
hétéroclite des manifestants
est ce qu'aujourd'hui ce qui les lie
tous finalement c'est leur défiance à
l'égard d' emmanuel macron
il ya plusieurs ya plusieurs paramètres
il ya d'abord au des gens qui sont tout
à fait rétifs à l'idée de vaccination ne
sont pas forcément majoritaire il ya des
gens qui eux considèrent en effet que le
pass sanitaire constitue un engrenage
qui est un engrenage dangereux pour les
libertés publiques et qui manifestent en
effet pour tout simplement
défendre cette idée des libertés
publiques et des libertés individuelles
et puis il y à aussi en effet un courant
qui est profondément aujourd'hui opposés
à emmanuel macron dont les gilet jaune
selon l'une des expressions au parmi
tant d'autres merci beaucoup à nos
benedetti rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire